Transcriber: Mennatallah Said
المدقّق: Anwar Dafa-Alla
هل تصدق أنني لم احدث نفسي
بهذه الطريقة المحفزة أبدًا.
مرحبًا، كيف حالكم يا شباب.
أسمي هو شروق غلاب.
لن استطيع أن أتفاخر، حسنًا
أنا شخص بسيط جدًا
ومن يعرفني يعلم اني متواضعة.
أنا سعيدة أنني معكم هنا اليوم في TEDxTalks
هل يمكنكم سماعي؟
جيد
لأنني إلى حد ما
قادمة لتكسير بعض المحظورات
ربما لا تعرفون لكني لا أحب
الخطابات التحفيزية
أبدًا.
لأنني أحيانا أشعر قليلا أننا
نبيع للناس الهواء في قوارير
وأنا غير قادمة لفعل ذلك، أبدًا.
أنا لن أحكي لكم ماذا عملت وأين
تحركت طوال العشر سنين الماضيين،
حيث يمكنكم إيجاد ذلك على
لينكدإن بمنتهى البساطة.
ويمكنني أن أتحدث عنها بعد محادثتي.
إنني سأتحدث اليوم عن شيء أنا
أثق أنه يمكنكم إيجاد
محاضرة أو اثنين أو ثلاثة أو عشرة
أو أي شخص أخر تروه بعد ذلك.
يحكي لكم عن فكرة المخاطرة والخروج من منطقة
الراحة وأنها سيئة وغير طيبة
ونحتاج الخروج منها، والفيلم ذلك بأكمله
ولا يوجد لدي مشكلة به إطلاقا،
حيث من يعرفني جيدا أيضا أو شاهد
حسابي الخاص على لينكدإن
سيجد أن حياتي عبارة عن مخاطر بجوار بعضها،
أنا فعلت ذلك، لن أكذب عليكم
لكن الفكرة أو ما أريد قوله
اليوم لكي أكون صادقة،
لا تجازف بدون حساب عواقب ذلك
المخاطرة المدروسة، ذلك تحديدا
ما سأتحدث عنه
كيف تقوم بمجازفة مدروسة.
سأحكي لكم عن أول قصة أي أول مخاطرة
في حياتي لأنني جازفت كثيرا
ولأن الوقت لن يكفي لذلك.
اللقطة الأولى أنني فتاة
مجتهدة جدا في الكلية
ألتحقت بصيدلة أنا مجتهدة
للنخاع ودرجات كثيرة
ومثل أي طالبة مجتهدة في العالم
كنت أحب إدارة الأعمال والصيدلة ولدي رؤية
وهي أنني عندما أتخرج  أقوم بالدخول
على شركة أدوية كبيرة جدا
وأعمل ضمن فريق التسويق الخاص بها.
ذلك الحلم، يجب أن أحققه، وهذا كل شيء
كل الفكرة أنني حققت ذلك الحلم، وسرعان ما
تخرجت قمت بالإنضمام إلى واحدة من
أكبر الشركات العالمية في مصر شركة نوفارتس.
وبالفعل كأنني أمسك السماء بيدي.
بعد ذلك،
جاءت لقطة أنني دائما مجتهدة
وأحب إتخاذ الخطوة التالية.
قمت بالتقديم في اسلسكا كلية الدراسات
العليا فى الادارة لكي أستعد للخطوة التالية
وأبدأ مذاكرة التسويق ودراسة
التخصص الثاني وهكذا،
وأبدأ في التواصل داخل الشركة.
إذا يعرف احد مجال الصيدلة سيعلم أنه
عليك أن تبدأ أولا كمندوب مبيعات طبي.
ثم إذا فكرت في الترقية إذن ربنا يوفقك هناك
بدأت أيضا أكون علاقات داخل الشركة
وأشاهد الناس الذين يعملون تلك المهنة
ماذا يفعلون بالضبط في يوم عملهم.
وهنا أخذت أكبر صفعة في حياتي
اكتشفت إن المندوبين بشركات الأدوية مع
كامل احترامي لهم يعملون مهام
ليس لها علاقة بالعلامات التجارية
وليس لها علاقة بقسم الإعلانات
الذي كنت أحبه وشغوفه به ولكن هم
يعملون أكثر من منظور المبيعات
أشياء متعلقه بالتنبؤ بالمبيعات
أشياء لها علاقة بالتخطيط المالي
وذلك لا يعيب أبدا ولكن هذا ليس ما تخيلته.
وهنا أخذت الصفعة وهى أن الحلم الذي
سأدخل من أجله الشركة قد أصبح محطم
غير نافعة فلا أريد ذلك بعد الأن
فكان حينها أحتاج أن أرى
ما هى الخطوة التالية
وهنا كانت تلوح الراية الحمراء في الأفاق
يبدو أننا نحتاج إلى الذهاب وترك الشركة،
الشركة التي يحسدك الناس على دخولك إليها
والتي يقول الناس دائما كيف أنك خريجة
حديثة واستطاعتي الانضمام لها
وكل الناس تقول هذه لا يمكن تركها
يا جماعة لا يمكن تركها
لا شيك دفع ولا فلوس لا يمكن تركها
وماذا ستقولين لأهلك، حيث لن نكون
قادرين على العمل بالصيدلة بعد الآن
أمي، طبيبة، ماذا سنفعل
حينها كان من الممكن بمنتهى البساطة أن أبدأ
في المجازفة وأقول السلام عليكم
وأجلس هنا أحكي لكم كيف أنني حققت حلمي
وجازفت فورا، ولكن سأكون بالفعل كاذبة
أنا لم أفعل ذلك، وذلك ما أريد أن
تفكروا به قبل أن تجازفوا
جلست وخططت، حيث أمسكت بقلم وورقة،
ولكي أفعل ذلك، ماذا سأفعل تحديدا.
وخمنوا ماذا؟ متى قدمت
استقالتي، قدمتها بعد 8 شهور
لأن الخطة التي وضعتها كانت تحتاج 8 شهور
فكان يجب أن نصبر ونظل مستمرين
في العمل حتى نحقق الخطة
خطة بمنتهى البساطة كان بها جزء نفسي للغاية
لتجهيز الثمن الذي لم يكونو جاهزين أبدا
لحد الأخر أنني لن أكون طبيبة بعد الآن
والخطة كان بها أجزاء متعلقة بالمذاكرة
لأنني احتاج، فأنا لدي خبرة في الصيدلة
وليس لدي خبرة في التسويق فكيف
سأعمل كمسوقة وليس لدي خبرة
أنني لدي مذاكرة كثيرة جدا، ولدي
أيضا مذاكرة في التخصص
حيث قد دفعنا المال، وهناك ماجستير
وأشياء دفعنا من أجلها المال فلا يمكن
وهناك جزء مالي، فأنا دخلت هذا الشيء لأنني
كنت أقبض جيدا ومعي أدفع قسط باليورو
لكن لو قدمت استقالتي غدا
فكيف سأدفع الأقساط؟
جلسنا نقوم بهذه الحسبة كلها، حسبة
الأقساط التي علينا لمدة سنتين
حسبة أنني عندما سأبحث عن عمل، سأقوم
على الأقل 3 أو 4 شهور بالبحث عن عمل
فيجب أن أغطي مصارفي الخاصة بي،
ولا أريد أخذ الأموال من أمي وأبي، فأنا لست
طالبة في المدرسة أو الجامعة بعد الآن
فكان يجب أن نجلس ونضع هذه الخطة
هذه الخطة استغرقت 8 شهور لتنفيذها
بدون الخوض في تفاصيلها أبدا
ولكن كل ما أريد قوله لكم
أن حقيقي 8 شهور ويوم انا قدمت استقالتي
وحقيقي انا راضية جدا جدا عن ذلك القرار
ولو فعلا لم أخذ تلك ال8 شهور في التجهيز
أنا كنت أخذت أكبر خدعة في حياتي لو كنت
سمعت كل محادثات TED
وكل الحاجات التي تقول اتبع شغفك
لأنه كنت ممكن أن أدرس تخصصان معا
لأنني لن سيكون معي المال لدفعها.
كان ممكن عندما أذهب إلى أي مكان لأعمل به
أقول له ليس لدي ملف نماذج الأعمال
أو دراسة حالة أو أشياء لأنني لم أذاكر
ولم أدخل تدريب بجانب العمل
ولم أفعل أي شيء من هذه الأشياء
فكنت سأخذ مقلب حلو جدا،
فلو سمحتم لو سمحتم لو سمحتم
نعم اتبع شغفك وأذهب وراءه
وجازف ولكن احسبها جيد جدا
وبالمناسبة أنا حاليا أعمل في التعلم
الإلكتروني ومصممة تعليمية
بغض النظر عن الوظيفة لأننا لازلنا حتى الآن
نحاول أن نشرح للناس ما هذه الوظيفة
ولكن هى شيء متعلق
بتطوير المناهج التعليمية،
أقصد التعلم الإلكتروني،
منصات التعلم الإلكتروني.
فأنا بالمناسبة أيضا قمت
بعمل تغيير مسار وظيفي
للقطة الثانية وكان يمكن أن تأتي لقطة أننا
نستخسر السنين التي عملنا فيها بالتسويق
ولكن أيضا عندما فعلت ذلك قمت بحسبتها، كيف
استفاد من الخبرة التي لدي سواء بالصيدلة
سواء كانت تسويق، أنا بالمناسبة في المنتصف
فتحت مشروع ما سوف أحكي عنه لاحقا
ولكنه استغرق مننا 3 أو 4 سنين كذلك.
وبعض ريادة الاعمال وأشياء كيف سنستخدم
ذلك في هذا الخليط وأيضا وضعت خطة محترمة
استغرقت حوالي 3 سنوات لكي أقدر
حاليا الخلط ما بين أنني مستشارة تسويق
لبعض الشركات الناشئة
وإن أنا قادرة على العمل
في جزء التعلم الإلكتروني
واعمل في أجزاء تعلم إلكتروني لها علاقة
بريادة الأعمال والتجارة والتسويق.
بالفعل ذلك الخليط لم يأتي أننا استيقظنا
الصبح فنفعل ذلك، نتوكل على الله بالطبع
لكن لو سمحتم اجعلوها مخاطرة
محسوبة، لا تقوموا بالمخاطرة هكذا.
أنا خلصت
وكنت مبسوطة معكم
واتمنى تكونوا استفدتم.
سلام عليكم أتمنى تكونوا استمتعتوا بذلك
مع السلامة. (تصفيق)